willkommen
beim live danke vier mal dass du sie
glock tesch und danke vielmals für die
schöne kommentar viele schöne und war
doch nicht so schön aber mir gar nichts
mal ein paar dura und rede mit den
nanometer domenica wo jetzt irgendwo
gattin norweger und die wächst also pink
panther scheck ich finde es schade dass
wellen läufer nur mit dem lebensstil von
weniger beleuchtet wurde es gibt
menschen wie mich die einen 15 job haben
und bereits längeres in einem bus wurden
stimme zu gerät das nur lebenskünstler
oder abnormale auf vier rädern leben
also durch recht es gibt ganz ganz viele
möglichkeiten zum wellness labour aber
die hand bewusst nur person moment am
anfang sogar mehrere lokal wo man denkt
er mit mir wäre elitären angemerkt nein
das macht storytelling mäßig bis 17 uhr
eine person begleitet von a bis z oder
vor anfang bis schluss und vor dem
herein nur einige und mittels bewusst
für dominique entschied abc.de bezüglich
generation wo seit nahe winter doppel
oder kein 15 jobprofil gefahr und ich
möchte frei sie und können egal wéi vill
boni will und deshalb helmut domenica
knop im vollen bewusstsein dass es noch
viele andere modelle vorweisen erwischt
hast du absolut recht
wer eine glasschicht die tendenziell
negativer voreingenommenheit des
reporters ist unschön es ist gut dass
wenn auch kritisch zu betrachten aber
seine ständigen kommentare sind nicht
wertschätzen also ich finde es überhaupt
nicht dass sie nicht wertschätzen oder
negativ xiii bin oder grundsätzlich bin
ich sicher nicht so als wäre nicht
wertschätzung gegenüber domenica und so
dass das mit ausgestreckter hätten nur
das was ich immer mehr auf augenhöhe ich
sie und dominik gust dass sie alle
kritischen fragen stellen und von dem er
also eher als überhaupt nicht gefühl
dass sie
negativ bilden was hat der ständig
direkt wir können dir bewusst aber jetzt
mit dieser haltung das thema in und um
das soll denn genau die attribute und
deshalb habe ich halt auch minimale
kultur das event live ist aber nichts
trinkt und finden für mich persönlich
war spannend was natürlich zu hören was
der manager zur seite jetzt ist sie gab
der selber für holger
also der weniger heu auf norweger
ja wie hättest du denn empfunden mit mir
super negativ empfunden oder wasser
steigern
es ist also unter dem motto vecsey
wowereit muss man sie erst mal nicht
sofort wir die electronic arts and the
bee haben oder unterwegs trifft das ich
mega unklar sie aber ich bin mega cool
the star of
existing will das ist genau das was ist
die einfindet kempe die andere nicht und
ich seit ich kenne blüten im umfeld oder
im entfernte umfeld wo wir sind keine
früheren wo sich als bisschen kauft kein
drama le faire sind von hoops doch nicht
so das ding
wieder denken wir doch einmal eine bach
katarina half brain buddies ex-chef ich
hoffe domenica dann werde ich selber
schwarz angemalt jeder der schon mal
sein auto im sommer in der sonne hat
stehen lassen weiß dass schwarz nicht
gerade die coolste farbe dafür ist ja
wir haben es mit sechs ja sagte ich dass
ich relativ gleich auf ihre farben ist
autofrei
hat er schon so schwarz kauft findet
aber auch subtiler inkognito danach zum
beispiel eben um das auto praktisch
nicht und ich meine sexy schaute sich
mega wenig zeit im auto verbringen also
ich bin fast den ganzen tag
bekomme ich sage nicht mehr mit über und
ja wenn im alarmierte bin und warum
heute nach es ist so und da wusste ich
ja wie soll ihr das sicher nicht ganz so
heiß drinnen wir vielleicht in ein
gewöhnliches auto
blieben die veteranen kelchen schrieb
schon eine längere regelzeit bringen
bringt manches schnell auf die spitze
jetzt sehr auf instant relativ viele
gegner die letzte hektische serie
gegangen ja also wirklich wenn es auch
nur schlechte richtig werden live mega
cool wie xhaka ich bin ein schnitt so
unterwegs zum citroen verbringen
hessischen doch es
gab auch nach sie sind schwierig zum
trocknen und zu
ja ich nicht optimal was aber auch sehr
cool ist mir eingefahren jedoch zieht
irgendwo anders angefahren das heißt
nicht mal sah man den hang besser da
steht plötzlich vor ihr noch formal 1
stunde und hofft dass tänzerisch was
auch immer komplexer und dahinter und
winter ja wir machen du das im winter ja
also mafioso in wien unterwegs sind die
flüchteten kinder ins wieder her so zu
gesprächskanal rechtshängig oder
südportugal oder so wie mir ich habe so
ich habe ja im winter schnee ich lebe es
auf der piste sie und einfach so das
ganze gefühl
russischer bronze für das ist gleicht
also als ugly und
als ich 15 jahre
und datum mache mache ich es auch so
dass ich dann
irgendwo immer eine richtige haus
verbringen sexy stars
irgendwo im skigebiet oder meist war es
aber es gibt schon möglichkeiten an war
fragt mich würde interessieren wie
domenica ihre lebenskosten rechnet mit
wen ausbau abschreibung des wellen
kosten für benzin stellplätze ich kann
nur schlecht vorstellen dass dies
günstiger ist als eine kleine wohnung
ja also pflicht zum ausbau ich habe ihn
wenn name ist bislang sehr sehr günstig
kauft haben auch wirklich alles selber
gemacht
handelt da costa relativ kalte und so
schwierig weil ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
genau aufschrieb wie viel geld es sowas
gibt ich weiß also was mit benzin kostet
sind und durch den einbau die snow und
ich manches oder phasen für den
lebensstandard hätte also wo ich hier
wohne hier lebt bleibt meist im alltag
ich meine zum spiel ich ach ja immer für
mich selber
kreuzkapelle land wie norwegen die
kinder regelmäßig auswärts groß sei es
ist schon happig der unterschiedlichsten
nötig gang in die ferien oder
kommilitonen irgendwie ein cocktail und
guten akku es sei sondern dass wir ganz
normal das ist mir das instinkt und für
eine frau in meiner du schon jetzt
sicher nicht wenn man fährt und sich
heute mal ein bisschen und und der maler
bis könnt für mich oder verfehle ich das
wäre sensationell eigentlich gott wäre
die sensation die 'hast du gar nicht
oder schon
politische mögliches neues erlebnis im
ausland
kurzum foto sie aber ich glaube der
unterschiedlich habe ich am meisten zu
viel härter aber setzt zum beispiel für
norwegen schweden ich mir jetzt einfach
gesagt hat nicht mal ungefähr 42 meine
zeit so lange es nur einigermaßen warum
ist das heißt wir natürlich viel
langsamer und so wächst sie haben viel
mit und jetzt stell dir mal vor ich will
jedes mal täglich ganze stadt ja schon
andere spiele boccia seither das jahr
zwei wochen august zur folter und wieder
zog der
nato steht ich bin etwas zwiegespalten
auf der einen seite lädt man nicht um zu
arbeiten sondern arbeitet um zu leben
das macht sich schon richtig solange
wenige diese haltung einnehmen ist das
gesellschaftlich tragbar und man kann
sich für jene freuen aber im großen und
ganzen verläuft diese freiheit auf dem
rücken anderer
der kommentar hätten verschiedene frauen
ab da malt ein fenster zu den eppsteiner
hat den ideen im luxus aufdrucke vor der
von rechts foto gesellschaft ich finde
das normal mehr richtig differenziere
ehrlich gesagt nicht für mich weg ein
burkaverbot im lab und es ist also wie
es nur die villa hieß jetzt bist du ich
meine ich vermiss eigene geld ich
war da nicht plötzlich machtspiels
carola ob ich jetzt da in norwegen oder
in südamerika oder ob ich ohne die der
schweiz will ich das für über alles
ramacher und denn ich sehe mir selber
über lob gern nach die jeder zweite tag
mit schlafplatz ändere oder ob ich halt
nicht fix in rabbanis sehen und das hat
auch dazu ermutigt immer so dass das
kann ich nicht alle live das hat nicht
alle machen aber das sind ja auch nicht
alle macht also
koller für besitzer selber
wieder eine schöne reportage danke was
ich mich frage wie viele von denen
würden noch wenn live machen wenn es
mobiles internet notebooks und so weiter
nicht mehr geben würde
ja auch so wahrscheinlich genauso viel
wird nicht mehr machen wir ein
faszinierendes prozent vom rechtsschutz
nämlich eine chance will halt
alles digital ist ich bin natürlich sehr
auf akquise auch immer mal wieder
internet sei zu keiner schaffte aber das
ja
ich sicher im bereich mehr nach so das
ist aber auch nicht so wie alle anderen
bereich praktische so wunderbar denn
wünsche dir noch angereist oder norden
dank und das dürfen sie mit weniger
wegen
der bislang strom fakt ist es nur im
kanton glarus streng mit dem camping
verbot ich dachte in der schweiz sei
wild campen kein problem außer natürlich
steht explizit das camping verboten ist
ja das jetzt einmal um sechs ort der tcs
schritt folgendes dazu hören wild campen
ist mit einigen wenigen ausnahmen
generell verboten ausnahmen bilden die
skandinavischen und baltischen ländern
sofern bestimmte regeln eingehalten
werden die vorschriften für das parken
von wohnmobilen und wohnwagen sind
streng definiert und sollten im voraus
konsultiert werden ja also der schweiz
ist tatsächlich relativ streng geregelt
dass ich eigentlich an bord der überall
mit wenigen ausnahmen und das ist ja man
muss einmal wirklich vom campingplatz
soll ein klassischer oder was ist auch
geht sind so
apps wo man sich kann verbinden mit blut
wie zum beispiel tourer wo ihre felder
zur verfügung stellen gegen gegner mit
geld oder auch food also es ist bis die
komplizierte als einfach irgendwo an der
steller und kroatisch im vergleich zur
über norwegen wo domenica jetzt kann man
eigentlich überall canada go the
collector lukas hat sich gefolgt und
hätten über genau dass das video gemacht
denn am schluss klinker ja das ist sie
track geht es nächste woche wieder doch
stimmt ganz gut
[Musik]